on à adrien 80's député la france a
soumises du nord vous pensez que la
sécurité ne peut pas
voilà peut pas être assuré de mon nom
j'ai pas dit ça je sais pas pourquoi
mais présentait sous cet angle là moi au
contraire je savais j'appartiens une
organisation qui contrairement à ce que
croit monsieur pomare plutôt en cas de
mobilisation garante du bon ordre c'est
à dire que l'aah bon il ya quelque chose
qui tient à la forme particulière de ce
mouvement d gilet jaune qui est auto
organisé et c'est pas notre rôle à nous
d'y donner des consignes et vous savez
moi je discute régulièrement avec les
autorités quand on organise des
mobilisations
généralement elle apprécie plutôt au
travail parce qu'on n'est pas du genre à
mettre de l'huile sur le feu ah bon mais
plutôt lentement on est avant tout et on
avait échangé un serrage avait demandé
demandé demandez à vos collègues vous
savez vous avez reculé les policiers le
magnat verizon suppôts marc vous pouvez
vous être des seniors la démocratie
monsieur actionner moi je suis maire
monsieur pommard jumère monsieur est
très bien mais en santé monsieur est un
jeune député aujourd'hui monsieur pomas
oui est ce que vous réserve afin de
chercher vos éléments de langage n'y a
pas de les utiliser les autres
politiques pas avec moi je me suis tout
de suite monsieur pommard n'a pas marché
pouvait me laisser parler un instant et
pas dit attendez deux minutes parce que
on va on va vous donner la parole sur
des mauvais on s'assoit vous que ça vous
plaise ou pas confiance ça ne plaît pas
du tout à faire vous avez en face de
vous un républicain convaincu conséquent
d'accord non c'est pas la charge et le
parti et vous rendez compte un peu
monsieur nzolo de soi même et je vous le
dis droit dans les yeux une situation
pareille
attendez chacun sait que vous
représentez et d'audience n'a cessé de
jeter de l'huile
cbg je ne loue n'est pas républicaine ne
vous attardez vous les airs ebe qui
essayent de gratter quelques voix sur le
malheur des gens voilà ce que je vous
dis vous marcher main dans la main j'ai
honte de ce navire est depuis le début
c'est la sénologie 4 il ya des gens qui
sont pas du tout mon bord politique y
compris qu'ils nous disent que ce que
nous faisons et ce que je fais moi
également
et bien fait que nos propositions sont
de plus en plus audible qu'à l'épreuve
des faits elles sont crédibles et
raisonnable ce qui vous déplaît
ça passe à jouer sans de l'eau vous
savez à l'instant ce que vous venez
faire en cherchant à m'écraser
finalement vous servez makusha pas que
je cherche pas à tout le monde ses
effectifs est ce que vous dites mais
c'est la république c'est vous qui venez
de vous ridiculiser je suis arrêté à
l'eau mais ce n'est pas pire est contre
la république pour n'est pas vrai voilà
je me sens vous vous l'été d'une gravité
soit je le maintiens et vous savez c'est
vous qui tenait des discours de guerre
civile dans ce pays or et à l'instant
c'est vous qui me suivent est-ce qu'il
n'est possible de déclarer monsieur
marage des kills de suite à leurs frais
les policiers ont remarqué que depuis
tout à l'heure car pour lui ce que lui
monsieur poma celui pommard depuis tout
à l'heure
celui à qui vous contesté les faits qui
est républicain vous a écouté par les
supporter que je parle quelques instants
et c'est le far west en attendant vous
pouvez dire ce que vous voulez mais
c'est vous qui vous comportez n'est en
rien porté en avant et républicain à
cette heure monsieur pomas je vous dis
que le mouvement des gilet jaune est
auto organisés mois pour y avoir
participé
je sais aussi que depuis plus d'une
semaine vous avez des tas de français
qui sont mobilisés qui souvent sont des
efforts considérables pour se mobiliser
pour la première fois de leur vie et je
le dis qu'ils ne se sentent absolument
pas représentés par les images de
violences que nous avons vues dans
toutes les manifestations les gens
viennent me voir en disant donnez-nous
les nouvelles de paris parce que nous
voulons pas être à malgré la violence
moi je vous le dit même si ça vous
déplaît
je préfère toujours les mobilisations de
masse déterminé mais dans le calme mais
y est c et c'est ce que nous appelons là
et de l'air est écrite moi même
est-ce qu'on s'aimait attitude
républicaine en question ou parce qu'on
peut assurer et bien sûr qu'on l'a peu
moins coûté à toutes celles et ceux qui
montrait même si je n'ai pas de
consignes à donner au mouvement des
gilet jaune parce que je ne suis pas son
représentant
j'ai un conseil à vous d'avoir essayé de
les interroger répondants ont pas durer
mais c'est râpé sénologie vous donner
encore plus que manolo est tous des
routes vous êtes des faits sont répartis
vous êtes bouffis de certitude si vous n
vous hanter mais ce matin là alors je
suis sûr ne cherche pas être aimée
contrairement à vous savez si ça vous
déplaît ils n'ont plus de cours d'examen
au moment politique c'est que
ce qui se passe dans le moment si vous
avez cette france invisible qui a décidé
de se rendre visible et maintenant elles
portent des revendications claires alors
on peut considérer ce soir de l'attitude
il avoue noyer le poisson considéré que
tout ce qui est politique est par nature
suspect en attendant moi j'observe une
chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui quand je
regarde les jeunes qui souvent je
regarde les quand je regarde les cahiers
de revendications des gilet jaune
je vois des choses extrêmement clair
extrêmement justes c'est tout ce qui
m'intéresse vous reconnaissez vous
reconnaissez ce que nous avons proposé
parle d'une refonte fiscale
oui mais là mais évidemment non
messieurs sont des seconds
j'aimerais qu'on ressemble vraiment à la
sécurité peut-on assurer la sécurité des
français
oui nous le pouvons et gilet jaune c'est
d'abord et avant tout un mouvement
pacifique qui ne se sent par le sénat
attendu janvier mohamed écrit aussi pour
marc je terminerais là dessus plutôt que
de dire comme vous l'avez vous l'avez
fait alors d'appeler les forces de
l'ordre à casser la gueule tu avais la
première des choses que non non non elle
est très très stricte sur les casseurs
qui sont étaient mais n'utilisait pas de
langage politique que vous avez
l'habitude a dit son idylle avec vous
des moments que toi tu mélanges et ans a
été dit parlant de wegelin lider maximo
mélangeant au coeur ont le coeur jaune
aussi parce que effectivement ils
arrêtent ces deux là solidaires des
revendications est l'une des premières
impressions sur les cas ce avec yann à
plus de 2 millions d'heures sup les font
pas les ritournelles et policiers